hello and welcome to honest trailer
commentaries what if finest trailers
were longer and had us in them
Demerol has been called back to his
hometown much like the events of it too
but he'll be back next week is he from
Derry Maine yes and yeah today we're
talking about it - we've already done it
one Vardhan it the miniseries what a
journey a journey man I gotta be honest
I'm kind of tired of talking about and
watching it I think rabbits oh yeah it
is we're done with it yeah I'm mad at it
to give yeah they couldn't have picked a
worse movie to be tired of the movie to
be inside of that was English this is a
real long film I I'll say this I did not
enjoy watching it probably in less than
ideal circumstances you know on my
laptop the end it apart just being a
real bitter cream on about it but it
would probably me probably have been fun
to see this on a big screen because this
seems like there are a lot of moments
that were just begging to be yelled at
from a theater chair like don't go in
there
I don't know looked out and that's for
you
my first sentence of this video aside I
trust my judgment and my judgment
watching this on my laptop was that I
would have been angry or I had paid $20
to go see it okay it just seems like to
me there's like like a carnival ride
hence the clowns and the literal
funhouse like it was just you know
things popped out at you like to go into
Halloween Horror Nights right on the
Pennywise themed night it just felt so
much like revisiting the first movie I
just didn't it didn't feel like they
came up with new elements to add to it
it was just like what if they went
through the same process again but you
know growin up in like bigger CGI but
then also not grown up because here kids
more write really repetitive to the
first minister I'm just being off from
my Pennywise reveal my trailers trailer
so let's just jump in
in a world going through its second
Stephen King Hassan's the sequel to the
highest-grossing horror film is here and
the scariest part is the runtime 250
it's not real it's not a real pause
there were two moments when I looked
down I like stopped the movie and then
checked how much time there was left one
was an hour into it I was like surely
there can't be I stopped and checked it
only ten minutes in a long movie and
then a second long movie where par the
way to do it and it's still the same
beat of like it makes scary things
happen and they freaked out and the
scary things go away it was like I was
real and like how many times can you
play that it like I get that it would
still be scary for the people right
experiencing it like if you saw this
terrifying thing in front of you but for
us it's also like you know Pennywise are
coming like if I see one of them walking
by themselves I'm like what's up anyways
we've seen enough of these beats now to
where we can anticipate the beat coming
and it's not scary the best sequences
were when it was a child or someone who
wasn't in the losers Club interacting
with Pennywise because there was
actually some stairs involved because I
I missed it and I guess we talk about
this later is like he can kill people
who aren't the main characters right but
well that's the scariest moment in both
movies that this is that great because
the beginning is like what he rips
Georgie's arm off because you don't see
that coming
one horrible most of the time he's like
a prankster he wants them to be scared
for like 12 hours right scrappy endings
we're about a hundred clips of this
short done it just this fudgy somehow
makes Bill Hader unfunny
and Eddie literally married his mother
damn I thought this took place in Maine
at the front page of Alabama for Tom to
help him capture three big space balls
pause for a second like was penny wise
at any point he was a real clown who
lived in Derry no man I mean the only
the only evidence we have that he was a
real clown like moved to Daria's that
old lady but she's a manifestation of
him so just be making that up but I
guess not in the in the first one there
wasn't anything about like an old
carnival burn no there was yeah he like
took on it's that form it's a point but
yeah in the second one it's like here's
this pointless flashback to when dude
wouldn't smoke peyote with the Native
American people yeah and yeah yeah cuz
he can take it was just a monstery thing
of anything he was predates clowns
he's been there for billions of years I
wanted them to do a twist where guys
like if only there was a term for me a
man who wants to be funny and wear face
paint and then he sees penny wise and
he's like I'll be a clown
[Laughter]
comedic entertainment a lien from space
and then assume the role of penny wise
it just really digs being a clown
somebody's brother like some old lady or
way because all of them have different
fears that they weren't all traumatized
by a clown yeah
no he just like what I'm really scared
of lepers yeah you know that common
childhood fear of lepers let's talk
about this ending thing too because
because Stephen King just does this in
his books - and it's obnoxious like he
did it with Dark Tower there's literally
a chapter in Dark Tower words like
before you read the final chapter of
Dark Tower read this rant about endings
of the nature of writing so I can kill
time before you're in story disappointed
in me and just go back to Christopher
Pike books personal you're doing an
adaptation like no one I don't think
anyone alive you know what I'll say this
no one living like the second half of it
they've already done it they've already
done it badly once mm-hmm
there's a blueprint as to why it doesn't
work you're doing an adaptation if
there's like a ton of instead of just
sitting and going oh how do we make
should work just adapt a new second
chapter of it just do it differently
no one cares that's what they're going
for this damn I've got this CBS all
access span series yeah and they
actually went and like the showrunner
and Stephen King just like came up with
a brand new and good thank God because
the stand runs into a damn cliff right
and so yeah they this would be like if
they still did the ending of the Sampat
that they added one scene to be like
yeah we know yeah because the stand is
like 300 pages
a guy just deciding that like but stuff
doesn't count like that that's most of
the stand that is most of the 240 to 476
it's just a guy like wait if I just do
but stuff it just fix it like you had
this chance to follow up the most it's
the most successful horror movie of all
time yeah yeah all right me r-rated
horror movie all day it made so much
money you have you could have knocked
this out of the lake unless there's a
weird contract where Stephen King's like
yeah and they finally they just got him
to just give on the child orgy from
chapter 1 you don't touch chapter 2 and
that's great because you got to swap in
if I can't change your crappy ending I'm
just gonna make you talk about how you
can't write ya 700 lampshades lampshades
not even just the ending that's the
problem you're just it seems like they
kind of just didn't know what to do with
this whole chapter and like what what's
the sort of guiding structure and idea
behind it is adapting a 70s authors drug
tripped like drug addled weird journey
into turtle God's fighting clown demons
passing him that's a hard thing to be
asked to adapt but I think the same
reason it didn't work in the in the 90s
as well is because like there's
something very visceral and primal about
child versus clown yeah that's a rivalry
man versus nature child versus oh yeah
grunts versus ever orcas a cop there's a
lot of balloon monsters job what kind of
agent [ __ ] gets neg - dad nice makeup
is it real the after mention child
Argentina now get ready for a faithful
adaptation of part two of the TV
mini-series oh yeah connection that
feels like it's missing video game quick
other bands
just break the tension
it'll deflate it like a sad clown
speeders now pause just sent the note
that that doesn't make any sense I was
watching this at home and everyone at
the apartment went what it's free
association I just was excited becoming
flaccid to help sign up and now he said
yeah yeah I'm also just glad I'm in a
position in my life where I can send an
email like hey Spencer I look I'll
respect in the world brother you know
just I think the sad clown penis part is
work I will yeah I
this battle is yours Ben's opinion but
someone said Khan's penis yeah just
there on the southern when you pick
you're a sad clown penis in your mind
does it have white makeup okay yeah yes
for me I just let me ask you this it's
made of it looks like a balloon animal
I was gonna say if it's clown white
where is the clown nose yeah doctor
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's really from the film love the Mets
love it pause here for my other problem
and I got this problem at the first one
- all the monster designs look like
something from the live-action
scooby-doo movie like they are they all
are like from goosebumps or something
like they all look ridiculous I agree
with you but I think it's more for a
good because I get it's like what's
scary to a child like is sort of
everything's kind of refracted through
this lense of like these are eight
twelve year old kids were engaging with
this monster so of course it is sort of
large and live almost cartoonish monster
but when they're adults it should be
more like what an adult would find yeah
it started with skarsgård and then it
was morph into something horrific yeah
this one it just kind of started with
like an insanely contorted CGI horror
monster like there wasn't anything real
grounding it except like the Pomeranians
yeah yeah it would just be it would just
go straight to you know God of War
mini-boss yeah yeah I was so and and it
was so obsessed with Bill Hader and
what's the other ones named Eddie thank
you I don't know I don't care James
ransom I think it's the Casper but
weirdly obsessed with like their hijinks
and like I get it it's trying to set up
like Oh Bill Hader is like back with
like the love of his life or whatever
but at the expense of the movie they
feels like they're going way down that
and they're almost there and then they
don't finish turns it into Harold and
Kumar Go to the sewer right there's it's
so focused on them just being like the
dog I think they really a plan that the
love of his life was like our kid kid no
that was like his awakening realized
someone I love forever yeah romantic
beat though between there is it you are
right but it is like they're doing a lot
to build up to that beat and then it
never arrives then they even play it off
at the end like when Eddie dies
everybody else is like not too bad Eddie
buddy knew what he was getting into but
Bill Hader is like they definitely felt
like they were they were gonna go there
and then they just never went but just
at the expense of the whole movie
anytime you're like okay this could get
scary one of them is just like Spencer
you're getting saw like drug trips in
any movie that I really don't get cuz
they knew they weren't 100% sure they
were gonna do part two and they depart
one like it was a flop they wouldn't but
they think they had this plan if only
they knew how it was gonna go you've got
this book to work from you know where
the story's going like if you think you
might want to do some seeds with them as
kids like kids like we're secretly gonna
make a sequel without a secret sequence
Matrix Revolutions that that'd be yeah
you know it's kind of a franchise
potential thing if you really need this
scene with them in this in this bunker
and what's great about that is they
didn't really need that scene know any
of them they don't add anything except
runtime you might literally shower cap
it's like the one plot element that they
need that scene for is like well these
are Stanley shower caps that we burn at
this ritual that I'm doing it that
you've told me I suddenly now have to
care about yeah that's almost like video
game logic that's nine side question
where you all have to go back to these
other locations I almost have quests all
45 bottles of wine hidden throughout
Thetis and Dragon Age Origins right now
I'm very excited I'm so close but like I
also don't want to watch a movie about
me doing Inquisition I'm so sorry let's
keep let's go well there you go all
right because all the prime locations
and villains disintegrate
[Laughter]
the scariest
in a nod to both Stephen King and the
movie you're watching cause all the
ending is terrible not all your engine
take decider movie and the ending suck
yeah I got a plan get the [ __ ] out of
Dodge before this ends where someone it
bills books or sign it yeah I didn't
like the smell of chucks deer build the
slack-jawed local Bryce Dallas Howard
aunt Beverly kills dairy girls Joker
score E
I thought you mean the Joker losers ad
and buried Pharma bro the losers table
as our accordion stabbed us 2x shanks
were the memories underwater brother
Frankie the day that that was for us
underground I dread I know they don't
bring Eddie's corpse out with him but
they could have at least at a Funeral
Richie went to Stan's funeral and they
hadn't seen each other in 27 years just
for the round for real instead water is
at least as nasties good people by a
dream AG so crass ya think they really
went to san funeral that wouldn't make
sense so this is a joke he doesn't
really go to Stan's few neurons like I
know there's no funeral scene right if
there's the apartments for Mike drop
right that's the implication he's 6
there they remembers when they had
varmints yeah
ok well let's move on to viewer
questions and comments please from
viewers like you
Donovan pesto Raj did you guys really
not like I like the first one I like I
like the mystery of the phone because
it's terrible because I'm alone one that
did not like the first one either yeah I
don't like anything just change it just
fit cuz everything like we move did we
leave dairy and we don't remember things
and did today and then we come back and
we remember now all the sudden is none
of it works listening to Stephanie
Cuevas question for those who read the
book I'm sorry Dan isn't here
no he's a fan was there any way this
film wasn't going to suck I mean you
know on you've read it has the second
half of the book yeah I mean this
reflects some of the problems that the
book has but I do feel like I think that
core it's a good baby disagree with Jill
there's like I think at core there is
something interesting about the idea of
them fighting this this evil as kids
going away living these whole lives
I like this core idea coming back and
like reconnecting with these friends
that bond like I think there's a lot of
good Stephen King elements there it's
just buried in lampshades to like pare
down a lot of the extra stuff
there's the materials that you could
have used are in this movie it's just
surrounded by a lot of other stuff you
may be done I agree I like the core idea
a lot of we were traumatized as kids we
got out of Dodge now we have to go back
to prevent it from happening to other
yeah it's like it gives them active
choices back and you get rid of all the
thing that I liked which is Mike Mike
Hamlin the Isaiah Mustafa character he
like they gave him a little bit of like
a detective angle like he's really been
spending the time and dairy like I'm
researching this and figuring it out
like that's a cool angle you could have
used to give it more structure and more
of a sense of like momentum is they come
back and he's like okay here's the plan
we got to do this this and this this and
then like convince them and like work it
out I'm gonna do drugs and then yeah
maybe there's one element of the plan
that doesn't work but it feels like it's
that for a little while and then it just
gets so distracted by so much other
stuff and it doesn't have a through-line
so yes I do feel like there's enough
elements in there that could work you
could make it work there are I mean a
lot of his books are like 50 percent
great premise and then 50 percent like
he got bored yeah or something and maybe
you don't need it to be a miniseries or
a two-part maybe it could just be like
one two and a half hour movie and you
just pare it down or you just do the kid
thing and it ends very bleak Lee
come back and it still has 27 years on
29 years underground or whatever give it
10 years so it'll be back why TF are you
scared
why transformers why transformers are
you scared at the runtime end game the
irishman wolf of wallstreet lasted more
than three hours stop winning those are
good movies like we're not ahead of the
run time if it's all quality but if it's
a bunch of like filler then well yeah I
think and also for me horror unless it's
like a very slow ratcheting up of dread
just the build and release of tension
you can't sustain that for three hours
it seems like a lot of like comedy
comedies there's a reason why we all
settled on around 90 minutes to be able
to tell something like that yeah
anything else is exhausting yeah it's
all filler no killer and it's three
hours of it yeah it's repetitive and so
yeah when you're when you're repetitive
and very long that's when it's a real
drag wolf of Wall Street
it's propulsive tons of energy you're
just pulled through the whole thing it
doesn't feel long at all yeah and
speaking of all killer no filler
valuable lasted it chapter two even have
any kills think like in the guy the
beginning of getting diced and killed Oh
God Coulson Avengers Assemble note at
the end oh yeah I don't like that
god yeah from the book that's like
that's like the brutal like go bug yeah
that's how scary it is and anything he's
like no guys I killed myself on purpose
to rally you guys writing alternate
versions of line for Bill Hader Stefan's
starring section please go through the
monado's commentaries I don't think we
know that was version that came that was
lawn hitting a homer and walking off the
field yeah Gary
Stefan anyone there's got everything I
think we don't leave men you know stare
he's got everything it's got old poems
from eight-year-olds human old ladies go
through a lot of Bill Hader sketches it
took me way too long to be like Lindsey
Buckingham
[Laughter]
all right that's all for this week I
hope you enjoyed this and we hope you
enjoy next week
schedules got a little wonky is your
close so we'll see you then
thanks again
[Music]
you